Also, would wheatgrass shots be of any value to my daily routine?
Well, wheatgrass shots have been counted as big health benefits
from a lot of people over the years, and it could give you a boost of energy. It has
nutrients in it and things. The only negative to wheatgrass shots would be the possibility of gluten
in them. Now, it's been studied that wheatgrass, if cut at an early stage, I think it's less than
10 to 12 days of growth than it doesn't have gluten, and after that it does have gluten. So if you
have a gluten sensitivity, you're staying away from gluten for some reason, you just have to be aware
of that. So if you're getting wheatgrass at the grocery store or something, you don't know how
all this is how long it's been since it was cut if you're growing your own wheatgrass, that would be
a different scenario where you can keep track of that. If you don't have any gluten sensitivity,
you're not staying away from gluten for any other reason, then that's not something you need to worry about.
Wheatgrass shots in general, you can buy wheatgrass shots, I think, to add to your smoothies and
things like that tend to be fairly expensive per shot. I have never added them to mine, and I haven't
seen a benefit to do so. But it's the only thing that I'd be aware that I would be careful about is
gluten if you have a gluten sensitivity.